d'ici fin novembre 2016 san quentin en
yvelines aura son incubateur appelé sky
cube ce futur pôle de l'entrepreneuriat
réunira différents services pour aider
les startups de demain si on veut que
nos entrepreneurs ils réussissent
durablement
parce qu'il ya souvent une entreprise
sur deux qui tourne quasiment dans les
seins pour leurs années il faut plus
bétonné ses différentes phases de
croissance d'une entreprise par comblera
prendront leur apprend comment
bénéficier d'un crédit impôt recherche
comment déposer un brevet comment
trouver un partenaire financier durable
situé à 200 mètres de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines l'incubateur
accueillera une vingtaine de start up
sur une surface de 1000 m² et trois
niveaux
dès qu'il y en a une qui est en en
gommant ça grossier papon la passe au
deuxième étage donc à promo paul louis
halley pépinières ou là y ait d'autres
services plus adaptés à un niveau de
maturité
oui c'est quand même une étape
d'accélération pour pour les plus jeunes
pour les jeunes hommes d'expérience bien
sûr ce qu itunes est aussi des espaces
de travail des salles de visioconférence
et des bases documentaires une structure
nécessaire pour les jeunes pousses du
territoire le tout pour un budget de 3
millions d'euros